jean de gliniasty chercheur à l'iris et
ancien ambassadeur de france à moscou
est avec nous sur ce plateau jean de
gliniasty
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe sur rt france alors
lors de cette journée de commémoration
on a entendu la volonté du président
russe n'a un sommet des membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu en 2020 une volonté approuvée par
le président emmanuel macron comment est
ce que vous comprenez vous analysé cette
volonté de vladimir poutine
je crois que ce type de proposition
s'inscrit exactement dans dans le dense
que doit tête le conseil de sécurité le
conseil de sécurité c'est un organe
s'occupe de la paix de la sécurité dans
le monde et à partir du moment où la
résurgence de l'antisémitisme de toute
forme de racisme de nationalisme extrême
ya tout un ensemble partout dans le
monde deux mouvements qui peuvent être
dangereux pour la sécurité dans le monde
et de sécuriser le conseil de sécurité a
véritablement pour fonction d d'essayer
de traiter ça donc je crois que c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président macron
tout de suite accepté la proposition
je dois dire aussi que ça à intervalles
réguliers le conseil de sécurité se
réunit surtout pour une raison pour une
autre c'est pas une fois par an mais ça
arrive souvent au niveau du chef d'état
et c'est un plus en plus un très bon
moyen de se parler de trouver une
occasion de régler quelques petits
problèmes entre soi et de se parler on
l'a constaté aussi 75 ans après il est
encore des noeuds dans la géopolitique
montréal on a entendu les paroles de
benyamin nétanyahou s'était rend ces
tyrans de téhéran donc en nommant la
politique iranienne
quel rôle peut jouer la russie justement
dans ce conflit parce que ça peut être
un médiateur la russie peut-elle être un
médiateur entre israël justement élire
en 2d
alors médiateur je peux peut-être que ça
pourra l'être mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'actuellement la russie notamment à la
fronde à la frontière israélo syrienne
est une sorte de régulateur
parce que d'une certaine façon elle
autorise ou en tout cas elle ne réagit
pas quand israël bombarde les le
hesbollah enfin les gardiens de la
révolution ou le hezbollah sur le
territoire syrien
mais jusqu'à un certain point donc en
fait la russie est partie prenante dans
la stabilisation de la situation à la
frontière syro israéliennes alors
maintenant ça peut aller plus loin et
comme la russie a de bonnes relations en
tout cas meilleur que les autres pays
avec l'iran et ce rôle pourrait devenir
un rôle de médiateur je ne l'exclus pas
alors un monument à la mémoire des
défenseurs de li ling rad a été
également inaugurer un ce matin on l'a
suivi en direct sur rt france pourquoi
une telle commémoration et est elle
importante 75 ans après en israël à la
fois pour l'état hébreu mais aussi pour
la russie alors le monument et aux morts
de leningrad c'est à dire pas forcément
aux juifs
en tant que tel donc le monument aux
morts de leningrad
c'est une grande cause nationale depuis
toujours tous les survivants du siège
dont leur petit diplôme de combattants
et de survivants et donc c'est un
élément majeur le siège de leningrad qui
a été terrible café bleu plus d'un
million de morts de l'histoire russe
récente et s'inscrit dans la célébration
qui va venir des du 9 mai 2 et de la
victoire sur les nazis qui est la vraie
fête nationale réussie faut le dire donc
donc ça s'inscrit dans cette volonté de
célébrer cet événement majeur qui est la
victoire sur le nazisme
les 75 ans de schwyz évidemment on y est
on y retrouve à ce moment là la
convergence à la fois d'un propres fins
d'une préoccupation global lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
et puis aussi il faut le dire disons les
préoccupations plus nationale d'un
certain nombre de dirigeants
on sait que natanyahou est en pleines
difficultés pour constituer un
gouvernement il va probablement
affronter de nouvelles élections donc on
sait en france aussi la résurgence de
l'antisémitisme est un problème
politique
on sait que par exemple
effectivement le président américain est
en pleine procédure d' impeachment est
en fait commémorer la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
la lutte contre le nazisme la libération
des camps de concentration
c'est pas forcément mauvais sur le plan
électoral sur le plan de politique
intérieure pour chacun de ses dirigeants
ou souviens c'était en juin dernier le
président vladimir poutine n'avait pas
été conviée aux cérémonies du 10 des
monts suscitant l'incompréhension
d'historiens de diplomate même vous il
me semble dans les colonnes du figaro
vous aviez fait part de votre
incompréhension
est ce que cette journée a également
permis au fonds de ne pas oublier ou de
rappeler certains pans de l'histoire en
occident plus précisément selon vous
alors sur le rôle de la russie dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale il ya des
statistiques très intéressante puisque
on voit que à la libération de la france
en gros il y avait 80 % des français qui
pensait que la victoire sur le nazisme
était dû à l'armée
soviétique à l'époque et maintenant vous
en avez à peu près la même proportion un
peu moins qui pense que la victoire au
nazisme a été due aux états unis à
l'armée américaine
donc effectivement c'est aux historiens
de rétablir la vérité des choses mais on
y aura toujours une tentation
fondée ou infondée de d'un certain
nombre de dirigeants que ce soit les
américains les russes les polonais
tsetta d'utiliser l'histoire leurs
profits ça c'est clair
merci beaucoup jean de gliniasty d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'iris ancien ambassadeur de france à
moscou et auteur de la géopolitique de
la russie aux éditions fayolle c'est
bien gérard ayrole je vous remercie